good screen joking opens the door
free god another bomb outside by murray
outside jokic for the lead
what a comeback by denver down
16. williams harrell
the collision the block shot by jokic
it's picked up by murray cross court to
yogic
in the middle harris murray fakes the
three step back
three chord hits another one
timeout clippers what a comeback for the
nuggets
trying to avoid elimination murray is
heated up for denver
talked to zoobots about that the other
day he had a real pragmatic approach to
it
coming into the nba from europe he said
he set little goals for himself as kawhi
hits the three he stays red hot guys
his goal which has been accomplished has
become a finishing five guy
harris outside in the corner gran here's
a three for denver
another one goes down the hatch
murray and beverly beverly's third
personal foul yokai chill t1 up from
three
got it again another triple for denver
[Music]
the best offensive murray
yogic down low no one there great
defense by
l.a it's george the other way
a little crossover on murray free on
that baseline what a
shot by george yogic on top
two-point lead denver it's winner go
home
three-pointer wow what a
bomb thrown up by porter
five-point denver lead
the rookie from missouri
right between the eyes with 111 to go
here comes george inside zubots against
porter
porter with the block porter with the
block it's outside
it's a three more snow rebound porter
inside
he lost the ball and a whistle michael
porter jr has done all right but how
about defensively the
huge block on zubats